a tsunami brought by the eruption of the
volcano Krakatau has left this coastal
village called lan terra behind me in
Bravos it is in this rubble that a young
father hopes that he will find his
three-month-old baby who has been
missing since Saturday the baby girl's
name is Anissa her body could be
somewhere in this debris fairy Cunha one
of fishermen is her father he lived with
his wife Hannah and their three children
near the water's edge their bamboo hut
couldn't withstand the force of the
giant wave this is all that's left of
our house my mother asked about the
strange sounds outside and when I looked
down I saw three big waves one after the
other I panicked and woke up my wife
we ran out with the whole family this is
where I got hit by the big wave we kept
running over there came the second wave
we fell again and that's when our baby
was torn from my wife's arms we're still
looking for her in this small village of
about 50 residents three people were
unaccounted for two bodies have been
found but ferry and Hannah's baby girl
is still missing in this one behind me
is where Hannah and ferry reunited with
two of their children instead of three
my baby was just wearing the new clothes
I had bought for her she had some new
toys too and she was just starting to
smile and giggle we wanted to go to a
family gathering but when the waves came
I couldn't hold on to her tight enough I
lost her
music thank God the tsunami left Hana
and Ferries family with only the clothes
on their backs and for now all they have
is this picture of Anissa and the hope
that she will be found that report was
sent to us by DW correspondent Anna
Santos and she now joins us from ab one
in western Java which is one of the
worst affected areas Anna we just saw
your heartbreaking report there on that
family praying for a miracle what help
is being provided for those with missing
friends and relatives and aid in general
well families like ferry and Hanna are
using every means possible to find their
missing loved ones ferry for example
yesterday we we found him at the command
post he had filed a missing-persons
report for baby Anissa and that would
signal the authorities to organize a
search operation for her but before that
he told us that immediately he sought
the help of his neighbors and other
loved ones in the village they were
digging through the debris with their
bare hands to see if they could find
Anissa and then after that the military
came to help them and again he asked for
their help in finding them so we see
that relatives looking for their loved
ones are trying every means possible
within what's closest to them and what
can offer the most immediate health and
then elevating these concerns to the
authorities now there are fears of
another tsunami ahna was the feeling
where you are
well right now you know there have been
continuous fears of another tsunami
hovering over us especially since we
continue to hear the rumbling of
Krakatoa
across from us and authorities say that
as long as the volcano is active there
might be the possibility of another
tsunami but today residents have to
contend with another more immediate
concern which is the floods if you look
behind me you'll see that roads like
this have been flooded up to about knee
or waist high some villages have been
flooded up to their rooftops this was
brought about by the continuous rain
which was torrential this morning and
brought these floods into these roads
and which further is hindering access to
for aid workers and relief goods to the
affected communities so right now we see
some kind of twin danger that or
disaster that aid and residents have to
deal with a possibility of another
second tsunami and these floods that
have been blocking access to roads and
just making life a little bit more a
little bit harder yet again for them ana
Santos and Labuan in western Java thank
you for that report